[Music]
right this January radical left-wing
California Governor Jerry Moonbeam Brown
he signed a bill into law making
California a sanctuary state in other
words California's lawless lawmakers are
now literally barring police from
determining the citizenship status of
anyone charged with a crime thereby
preventing the federal government from
effectively deporting criminal illegal
immigrants and enforcing federal law but
now some localities they are starting to
fight back now the city of Los Alamitos
that's in Orange County California they
voted earlier this month to actively
defy the state sanctuary status and
earlier today
Orange County Supervisors they followed
suit and they have voted to join
president Trump's lawsuit against
California and in the meantime all the
County Sheriff's Office is now
implemented a new plan to skirt
California's insane sanctuary laws they
are going to actually assist the federal
government in deporting illegal
immigrants convicted of serious crimes
and of course those standing in the way
of the rule of law now the plan is
really simple the Orange County
Sheriff's Office will now make the names
and release dates for every prisoner
publicly available in an online database
called who's in jail now this will allow
ice to cross-reference identities and
deport those illegal immigrants that are
convicted of crimes and of course a
threat to society and in response the
Attorney General of California while
he's now issuing a veiled threat to
those that challenge
California's sanctuary status which of
course defies federal law watch this to
take a closer look at what Orange County
is saying and possibly doing
state law state law and it's my job to
enforce state law
I will I will do so and we want to make
sure that every jurisdiction including
Orange County understand what state law
requires of the people and the
subdivisions of the state of California
I actually dare the Attorney General of
California to do this now if he does
that means the Oakland mayor can be
arrested by the federal government for
aiding and abetting criminal illegal
aliens by tipping them off that they're
going to enforce the law now we'll have
a lot more on this later in the show
when the Orange County Undersheriff will
join us also tonight the California
lunacy continues that state is now set
to sue the Trump administration yet
again this time over a question on the
upcoming 2020 US Census now the census
will ask non respondents or those that
want to respond are you a US citizen
that's it now the California Attorney
General tweeted that the question is
quote not just a bad idea but also
illegal
mr. Attorney General I beg to differ now
there was even more hysteria of course
in the left-wing abusively biased
so-called mainstream media watch this
what do we want from the Census we want
an accurate count
let's defer to the experts will this
help with accuracy it will not because
people will not answer the question
let's be realistic about this do we
think this is about getting an accurate
view of the census and protecting voting
rights or is it to in fact suppress
minority voting so the Justice
Department's motivation here seems to be
quite so a ruse for adding a question to
that could very seriously depressed
participation and result in a failed
census altogether what do you say to
critics who argued that ultimately this
is
to target immigrants that it's gonna be
fewer resources for immigrant
communities now the main goal of the
census has always been to determine
demographic information about the
population that lives inside the United
States but the left members of the bias
press they want you to believe that we
aren't allowed to determine how many
citizens versus non-citizens are
actually living here that makes no sense
considering congressional districts are
literally made up of what the population
is nothing says that responsible
immigration policy you know like well
who's living in your country really hard
question we'll have more on that in a
second now when it does come to the wall
on the southern border there is some big
news out of Washington according to
reports the president will use military
and national defense funding to cover
initial construction costs of the wall
citing what is a clear national security
risk presented by unprotected borders
this is a huge step forward for the
administration and it would be a
political victory and serious progress
of course to battle and secure our
borders now here's what the deputy White
House press secretary
Hogan Gilley had to say about this on
Fox and Friends earlier today the
president is now saying or he kind of
hinting around at least on Twitter over
the weekend that he could use all of
that military funding there was a lot of
military funding going into the
pocketbooks of those men and women that
are fighting for our country but there's
a lot of extra money to be used more
than what they asked for more than what
the White House asked for so there's
talk that he might use that extra money
to build the wall since he didn't get
the funding he he only got one point
women yeah right his Twitter was saying
we might use this to the military money
to fund the wall is that gonna happen
well I don't want to get ahead of his
announcement but I can't say this is one
reason that the announcement he's gonna
make announcement how he spends that
money to build the wall but I can't say
that's one of the the major victories
for the American people in this piece of
legislation that the president pushed
which was actually building a wall so
when the funding becomes reality
President Trump will be fulfilling a
major campaign promise and don't forget
the president has already started to
look for prototypes for this wall all
right another top story tonight the
destroyed truck press they are spinning
in circles after more than a year
obsessing
over Russia Russia Russia collusion of
the medias fragile narrative of course
is crumbling right before their eyes
now the left said the president Trump
would never ever be tough on Russia you
might remember this daily hysteria take
a look I think he's afraid of the
President of Russia why well no I think
one could speculate as to why that the
Russians may have something on him
personally that they could always roll
out and make his life more difficult
it's so clear at this point that
Vladimir Putin and his associates
somebody has something on Donald Trump
that maybe something that turns the key
and the Russia probe is figuring out why
this president is so deferential to
Putin and to Russia and if there is some
sort of compromise that they have on him
Donald Trump is afraid a political
hurricane is out there at sea for him
we'll call it hurricane Vladimir if you
will the whole Russian thing
they make these decisions time and time
again in in a way that makes it appear
that they're hostages that he's that
he's a that he's Vladimir Putin's
hostage
I was just last week oh they have
something on Trump he can't act against
Putin well yesterday the Trump
administration they announced tough new
actions against Vladimir Putin and his
regime in response to the poisoning of a
former spy and his daughter and Great
Britain oh the Trump policy includes the
expulsion of 60 Russian diplomats the
closure of Russia's consulate in Seattle
it's pretty tough make no mistake this
is a very aggressive move against
Putin's regime it sends a powerful
message that the United States and our
allies are not going to bow down to
Moscow and I guess they don't have
anything on Trump even former CIA
director turned CNN shill Michael Hayden
he's praising President Trump Wow hell
is frozen over
let's look so felt familiar felt a bit
like old times
now look look what just happened we are
tough on Russia we acted in concert with
our allies globally the United States
took a leadership role very untrim pian
and so I'm very happy to see it that we
can make you happy general Hayden is
right but some of the media they're
still doing whatever they can to
discredit president Trump's latest move
by the way Obama never did anything this
tough he was telling dmitry medvedev
tell Vladimir I'll have more flexibility
after the election watch this it was
almost like the old days with the United
States and its allies forge something of
a common position the not-so-good part
of this Joe this is foreign policy on
autopilot we still could have done a lot
more if we really want to hurt the
Russians and Putin specifically you go
after the banks here where this is still
a lot of Russian money being housed I
think what's happened is the Allies have
kind of shamed the president into this
action today we would be standing alone
very obviously if we didn't do something
it allows the president cover he can say
look I'm tough on Russia but Putin is
Putin is laughing at Trump tonight
because he knows he has license to do
whatever he wants
why did the administration send a strong
enough signal not yet if you want to
send a strong signal I think at some
point you got to look at some money
sanctions you got to get at Putin and
the individuals around him you mean like
president Trump pursuing energy
independence that is the heart of the
Russian economy and guess what that'll
hurt Vladimir Putin and any economic
chances of growth that he has I've told
you journalism is dead and buried in
this country so it's not surprising to
hear the media bending over backwards
the best President Trump even when he
does something really tough and strong
and good now you're not gonna hear this
from the so-called journalists over at
these other networks but it is important
to remember this is just the latest
tough action from the Trump
administration because they won't tell
you but earlier in March the president
announced critical new economic
sanctions against Russia in response to
election meddling in February around 300
Kremlin linked Russian mercenaries were
killed or wounded by the US military
that following Russia's aggressive
actions near a base in Syria where
Americans were stationed and of course
this all comes after President Obama
essentially did nothing but appease and
ignore and suck up to Vladimir Putin
year after year now Russia is vowing to
retaliate against the Trump
administration's tough actions oh maybe
they'll released the information they
have on Trump
but unlike the Obama administration
President Trump well he's not going to
take hostile actions by Russia very
lightly